I have Carrie thank you I'm Prime
Minister my question to yourself is
would the Conservatives reverse their
decision in to come back to the police
service which is now more than ever
overburdened and walk in a tie rope
without a safety net I was about that
first of all say thank you very much for
your service in the police I know that
you put your lives on the line every day
to keep us safe and I have huge respect
for what the police do for us but I was
about to say what a brilliant example
the police had been over the last five
years we did have to make reductions in
spending on the police so police budgets
came down by some twenty percent but at
the same time the police have done such
a good job that crime has come down by
almost twenty percent we managed to get
officers out from desk jobs onto the
streets we put more civilians into some
of those roles we made sure the and the
police did this themselves they combine
forces were combining an ordering
equipment and things together so I think
there's still some more efficiency that
we can get out of that but in the end
we've got to back the British police so
the best in the world to do a great job
and they'll always have my support as
far as I think you should police are
concerned though Prime Minister the
Chief Constable there said that it's on
the verge of collapse he said that last
December well I just I don't accept that
I mean I think you know I understand
they're under pressure she wrong I think
you look at lincolnshire in that County
as well you know crime has come down
because the police are doing a great job
and there's more we need to do using
modern technology to make sure that
crime continues to fall under this
government and if we do that then we
should be saving money as well let's
bring in Thank You Prime Minister let
digit were you happy with that response
so uh no comment okay